Part C find the particular solution W as
a function of T to the differential
equations derivative of W with respect
to t is equal to 1 over 25 times W minus
300 with initial condition at time 0 W
is equal to 1,400 and the units in this
problem it was 1,400 tons they told us
1400 tons so it might seem strange to
see a differential equations problem on
an AP exam you say well you know I said
this isn't fair this isn't you know this
isn't a differential equations class and
the thing to keep in mind is if on an AP
exam you see differential equations
they're really asking you to solve
differential equations that can be
solved using the skills that you would
learn in an AP class and the the main
differential or class of differential
equations that you could solve are the
ones are separable differential
equations the ones where you can
separate the independent and the
dependent variables and if you don't
have any idea what I'm talking about I'm
about to show you so let me rewrite this
differential equation we have DW DT is
equal to 1 over 25 times W minus 300 now
this differential equation we have W
here and we have this DT but we don't
have T anywhere else so what I'm what I
want to do is I want to get the parts
that involve W on to the left-hand side
and I want to get anything that deals
with DT on the right-hand side so let's
let's divide both sides of this equation
by W minus 300 so we would have 1 over W
minus 300 DW DT the derivative of W with
respect to T is equal to well I divided
this side by W minus 300 so it's is
equal to 1 over 25 now I want to get the
DTS on this side so let's multiply both
sides by DT viewed the differential is
just a very very small change in T and
so we get we get and I'm a little bit
imprecise with my notation here but this
is one way that you can think about it
when you are dealing with the
differential equations like this
separable differential equations you
have 1 over W minus 300 DW and make sure
that I'm that the DW doesn't look like
it's in the denominator DW is equal to
is equal to 1 over 25 d
and now we can integrate both sides
which is essentially just saying that
we're taking since this is equal to this
that each little increment of W times
this is equal to each little increment
of DT times 1 over 25 we can then say
well if we sum up all of the increments
of W times this quantity if we sum up
that the the infinite number of
infinitesimally small increments that
would be the same thing as summing up
all of these characters because each of
these characters is really the same as
each of these characters so let's do
that some we're essentially just taking
we're just integrating both sides of
this and here you might be able to do
this in your head or we could do the
formal use substitution just to make it
clear what we're doing if you said u is
equal to W minus 300 then what is D you
if you wanted a differential so if you
if you want to take the derivative of U
with respect to W you would say D U with
respect to W is equal to what it is
equal to 1 the derivative of this with
respect to W is 1 or if you multiply
both sides times DW you have d U is
equal to DW and so this left-hand side
right over here this integral could be
re-written as the integral of 1 over u D
U we define this as U and we just saw
that D U is the same thing as DW so this
could be rewritten as d U and this is
one of the basic integrals so hopefully
we've learned and this is equal to the
natural log of the absolute value of U
or if you were if you unwind the
substitution this is equal to the
natural log of the absolute value of W
minus 300 so let me write this down so
the left-hand side right over here and
you might be able do that in your head
you say hey look you have W minus 300
its derivative is 1 so it's essentially
there so I can just take this as if this
was 1 over I can just anti take the
antiderivative here and treat this whole
thing is kind of a variable so it would
just be the natural log of this entire
thing or the absolute value of that
entire thing so the integral the
integral of the left hand side is the
natural log of W minus 300 of the
absolute value of W minus 300 and the
the right-hand side is a little bit more
straightforward with respect to T or
sorry the inter the antiderivative with
respect to T on the right hand side is 1
over 25 1 over 25 T or we could say T
over 25 whereas T over 25 and then these
are both indefinite integrals you could
have a constant on both sides or one
side but we could just put it on one
side right over here you could have put
plus some constant you could have added
some you know c1 over here and then you
could have had c2 over here but then you
could have subtracted c1 from both sides
and then just have a seat three constant
over here but to simplify it you can
just say look we just we this is this is
going to be equal to this plus some
constant you could put the constant on
that side as well it doesn't matter all
the constants would kind of merge into
one now this is we've gotten pretty far
we want to solve we want to solve the
particular solution right now we only
have this constant and we also haven't
written W as a function of T just right
yet it's kind of a they're their input
implicitly expressed this is more of a
relationship than a function right now
so the first thing we can do is try to
solve for C we're told in the problem
we're told in the problem that W of 0 is
equal to W of 0 is equal to 1,400 tons
they told us that that's one of our
initial conditions so we know that the
natural log that when T is equal to 0 W
is equal to 1,400 so 1400 W is equal to
1,400 when t is equal to 0 is equal to 0
plus C or another way to think about it
is the natural log of the absolute value
of 1100 is equal to C and obviously this
is a positive value so we can just say
that C is equal to the natural log of
1,100 we can drop the absolute value
signs because the absolute value of 11
or it is 1,100 so now we can rewrite
this part right over here let me do it
in yellow let me start
that's not yellow let me start right
over here so we could write the natural
log of the absolute value of W minus 300
and actually we know that W is an
increasing function W starts at
1,400 and only goes up from there as T
gets larger and larger so if we're
starting at 1400 and only getting larger
and larger values for W this expression
right here is never going to get is
never going to get negative 4 positive T
values and that's all we care about and
so we can actually drop the absolute
value sign this will always be a
positive value so we could say the
absolute value of W minus 300 is equal
to T over 25 and we've just solved for
our constant plus the natural log of
1,100 and now we can just solve this
explicitly for W we can raise we can
raise e to both sides to this value is
equal to this value the left-hand side
is equal to the right hand side so
earase to this power is the same thing
as e raised to that power so we have e
to the natural log of W minus 300 is
going to be equal to e to the t over 25
plus the natural log of 1,100 and let me
let me take this let me actually just to
get the real estate let me delete that
alright now I can keep working right
below that and so e to the natural log
of something is just going to be equal
to that something the natural log is
what power do I have to raise e to to
get to get this thing well I'm raising
you to that power so I'm going to get
this thing so this the left hand side
just becomes W minus 300 and the right
hand side we could rewrite this as e to
the t over 25 times e to the natural log
of 1,100 all right we have the same base
different exponents you would if you
wanted to simplify this you would just
add the exponents which is exactly what
we did up here so these two things are
equivalent e to the natural log of 1,100
that is 1,100 the natural log of 11 our
is a power that you raise e to to get to
1,100 so if you raise e to that power
you get 1,100 so that is 1,100 so we get
W minus 300 is equal to 1,100 1,100 e to
the t over 25 and then you just add 300
to both sides w is equal to 1,100
e to the t over 25 plus 300 and we're
done we have solved the differential
equations we found the particular
solution we had to solve for C to find
that particular solution but we're done
and we did it using just basic
integration we didn't have to use any of
the fancy yeah differential equation
solving tools that you might learn in a
more advanced class